la question gênant d'avoir tu ne
révèlerai banque rubrique chaque jour
pour une caisse poser une question
gênante palais la question gênante c'est
pourquoi par bernard montiel aucun
chroniqueur n'a twitté pour camille y en
a plein voilà qui ont dit ça alors dit
la vérité
pourquoi aucun acte ou des problèmes
alors à l'abordage d'abord d'abord un
premièrement c'est vrai qu'on ne suit
pas pour la concurrence a priori c'est
un peu moi c'est monsieur posture ou
ajouté en plus c'était fade encore moins
se serait tu es france 2 france 3 p peut
peut-être faire un petit tweet je suis
très honnête avec vous et après
honnêtement j'étais pas forcément je
suis pas un proche de camille il savait
que j'ai pas pensé voilà désirait que
moi par une émission on ne doute pas non
plus jean michel naud twitter mais non
mais regardez cet après midi au replay
donc jamais moi c'est par bonté d'âme
comme j'ai vu vite qui faisait naufrage
la berd a regretté valérie moi je trouve
que de dire je trouve que de dire j'ai
pas tweeté parce que ces campagnes tout
à l'heure on a eu quelques uns étaient
là vous avez vu quelqu un texto qu'il
travaille chez tf1 vous avez pas fait
d'erreur vous avez lui son twitter mais
moi j'ai baissé la manière des sondes
chérie je vais y revenir là dessus et
moi je voudrais moi je vous dis pourquoi
j'ai pas tout et c'est vraiment dit les
65 cents mais je vous dis quoi kostia
non mais je vous dis je n'ai pas tweeté
parce que déjà j'avais chez tonton de
tennis et j'ai dû voir l'émission après
d'ailleurs j'ai pris une tannée et deux
non deux
c'est vrai que j'ai pas tous ici parce
que je voulais pas bien sûr je suis à
fond et camille mais c'était vis-à-vis
de tf1 j'avais pas envie de souhaiter
vis-à-vis de tf1 et camille voilà je
vous dis ce qui m'a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup touché c'est que j'ai pas pelé
camille ce week-end ce que je voulais
laisser se reposer et que ce matin j'ai
un appel je vois qu ami m'appelle et il
me dit voilà je voulais absolument avoir
ton avis sur ma prestation de deux
dalles soit il me dit voilà chez lui
tout le monde mais il ya une mire à
quelqu'un qui comptait beaucoup pour moi
c'est toi je voulais absolument savoir
comment tu m'as trouvé dans d'als et je
lui dis que j'avais été fier de lui
voilà que il avait gardé
voilà ce sont voilà ce qui fait sa force
qui faisait sa force ici c'est à dire
voilà son humour et qu'il avait su le
mettre au service du programme que ça
m'avait extrêmement touchée qui
m'appellent pour me demander voilà
comment j'avais trouvé sa prestation
vraiment j'ai trouvé ça vraiment il m'a
dit voilà j'ai jose et appelé ce
week-end mais j'ai dit allez lundi matin
je finis la radio faut que j'appelle
syrie pour savoir ce qu'il a pensé de ma
prestation puisque c'est important pour
moi est vraiment ça m'a beaucoup
beaucoup touché et je voulais lui dire
voilà camille moi j'ai été fier de toi
c'est ce que je veux dit ce matin
et je pense vraiment qu'il va ringardise
et tous les autres animateurs de tf1 et
qu' une nouvelle ère s'ouvre sur tf1 et
que peut-être avec cette nouvelle ère on
va peut-être être copains non mais parce
que vraiment je trouve qu'il a ramené un
nouveau truc après gille voilà vous
dites ici
il s'est pas voilà c'est sûr il a dû
faire un peu téva parce qu'il a dû
mettre un costume à ce que je vais nice
matin jeudi le pantalon large et est
fabuleux il m'a même bien un truc qui
m'a dit avait même encore l'étiquette
des chaussures à semelles voilà il m'a
dit interrogé t il m'a dit qu'elle était
très très stressé avant le prime et qui
s'était amusé comme un fou qu'il était
très heureux dans ce qu'il faisait il
adore se mettre au service d'un
programme mais voilà autant moi c'est
vrai que les formations se méfier jeu
vérité autant qu ami m'a dit je crois
que j'ai trouvé ma voie et je suis très
concentré nos services d'un format d'un
gros formats et voilà de m'amuser autour
comme ça et lycées ici avec laquelle on
va voir la semaine prochaine on fera un
petit point semaine prochaine mais c'est
vrai que voilà j'ai été très fier qu'ils
m'appellent est vraiment très heureux ça
m'a beaucoup touché à la joue camille
combal comment vous l'avez pouvait nuire
89% à dos nu et voilà donc la garde si
tu veux aller sur tf1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]